SRINI DEVADAS: Good
morning, everyone.
Thanks for coming in
on a Friday morning,
especially with the
long weekend coming up.
We're going to pick up
where we left off yesterday.
And so if you recall,
we were looking
at an iterative approach
to solving the eight queens
problem.
And in case you've
forgotten in the,
I guess, intervening 20 hours,
the eight queens problem,
which is a specific
instance of n queens
is you have a chess board--
and I won't draw
all the squares--
which is, obviously,
an 8 by 8 board.
And you want to place
eight queens on this board
such that no two queens
attack each other.
And we looked at different
data structures to solve this.
The naive data
structure would be
to represent the board as
a two-dimensional list.
And so you end up
having an 8 by 8,
if you have a chessboard for
the eight queens problem.
We looked at a 4
by 4 for starters.
And then after that, we
looked at compressing
that representation down to
a one-dimensional list where
let's say you had a 5
by 5 board because we've
got five entries here.
You exploit the fact that
there can be at most one
queen on any given column.
And you say I'm
going to represent
the position of that queen using
a single number where is from,
in this case 0 through 4,
if I have a 5 by 5 board,
and you put that in here.
So a minus 1 would
represent this being empty.
A 2 would represent a
queen in the second column
in this position over
here, et cetera, et cetera.
So with this more
compact representation,
it turns out that
the conflict check
becomes pretty straightforward.
And if you remember,
our conflict check
is incremental in the sense
that what you're going to do
is assume that queens
have already been placed
in some number of columns.
I mean, it could be zero.
In this case it's 2.
And you're going
to try and check
to see when a third
queen is placed
on this third
column, number two,
whether it conflicts
with the existing queens.
But you don't have to worry
about the checks associated
with the existing queens
because you've already
taken care of that.
So that's the incremental
nature of this check.
And I won't go over
this code again,
but the check
associated with ensuring
that when you place a
queen on a given column,
it checks the diagonals.
That's the most
interesting part.
And you put a queen here,
you need to check this,
and you need to check that.
And in this case, obviously
there's a conflict.
And because there are
two diagonals, that's
why you have the ABS, the
absolute value over there,
and you're exploiting the
fact that the diagonal is
a diagonal of a square,
and how much you move up
should be how much you move
to the right or down, left,
or what have you.
Another check is simply
ensuring that when
you look at the
particular column
and you see the number current
is a particular column,
the number associated with
that particular column
shouldn't be repeated
in some other column.
Because that would imply that
if you saw a 2 and a 2 here,
obviously, that
would imply that you
have two queens on the same
row, and you can't have that.
So that's the story.
And we decided to use iteration
because, at this point in time,
you know nothing else in
terms of control flow.
I know that's not the
case, but we assume that.
And so you end up
having this ugly code
associated with eight
nested loops that does
this incremental enumeration.
So board 0 being i implies that
you're taking the first column
and you're iterating
the positions
of the queen in the rows
of the first column,
and so on and so forth.
And if you go
ahead and run this,
which we did last
time you end up
getting 92 different solutions
to the eight queens problem,
and as I mentioned, there's
only 12 distinct ones.
So if you take rotation
and reflection into account
and each of these is
a legitimate solution,
that needs to be
translated into the picture
that you see here by
essentially taking this data
structure that you see.
7 becomes the queen in the
left corner, et cetera.
So we absolutely wouldn't
want to publish this code.
I guess, in effect,
I'm doing it.
But you would not want to
claim authorship of this code
especially if you know about
the programming technique that's
called recursion.
So that's really what
we're going to do today.
We're going to look at a
couple of different puzzles.
We'll finish up with the n
queen's puzzle fairly quickly,
and we'll look at how we
could use recursion, which
is an algorithm paradigm as
well as a programming paradigm
to solve challenging problems.
And there's really
two classes, at least,
of recursive
algorithms, and you're
going to see both
of those today.
The first one is nQueens, and
I'll get to the second one
when we get to the second one.
So our goal now is to take that
ugly code and make it pretty.
And before I get
into that, I want
to show you a simpler example
of iteration versus recursion.
And this is about
as simple as it
gets while still
being interesting
from an algorithmic standpoint.
So the greatest common divisor,
Euclid's age-old algorithm
to compute the greatest
common divisor.
And you see the two
line, three line,
what have you
iterative algorithm up
there that corresponds to taking
the pair of numbers, obviously,
m and n that you need
to compute the greatest
common divisor for.
And all you do is assign m
to n and n becomes n mod m.
And I'm not going to explain
why this algorithm is correct
or anything like that.
I'm not particularly
interested in that.
What I'm much more
interested in is
ensuring that you understand
that the iterative algorithm is
the same as the recursive one.
The recursive one gets
you the correct answer
if you assume the
iterative algorithm is
correct and vice
versa, and that's
really what this is about.
So we won't argue if
Euclid is correct or not.
But the point here is you
could have translated--
well, you did translate
this iterative algorithm
into a recursive one.
And there's a couple
of things I want
you to keep in mind when
you look at recursive code
and certainly when you
write recursive code.
And it's much easier
pointing this out
in a simple example like this.
So first off, when
we say recursion--
and I should have probably said
this a little bit earlier--
recursion is something
calling itself.
So you can say a function,
f, calling itself,
that's the simple case.
We also consider if
you have f calling
g, which calls f, then
that is recursive as well.
And see you can have
arbitrary structures that
correspond to nested recursion.
We're really only going
to be looking at functions
at least in this lecture, where
you have a single function, f,
calling itself, which
is exactly the case
for our RGCD, the Recursive
GCD that you see here.
You see a call RGCD
inside of RGCD,
and you know this
function is recursive.
Sometimes you may
look at a function
and you don't see that
immediate syntactic evidence
that the function is recursive,
but it may be recursive
because of nested
recursion, f calling
g, more complicated recursion.
So this is clearly a
recursive function, RGCD.
And two things that
you need to look
for if you want to write
correct recursion, I mean this
is not sufficient to
write correct recursion,
but necessary.
And in particular, when
I say correct recursion,
I want it to be
non-terminating, so the problem
with something calling itself
is, you think of it as there's
some sort of cycle
and you absolutely
need to break out of the
cycle, otherwise, you
will be in the cycle forever.
You could call something
which calls something, which
calls something that
goes on, your program
isn't going to terminate.
So you always want to be careful
when you write recursive code
that there's a base case.
There's a termination condition.
So there should be
some part of the code
where if certain
conditions are satisfied,
you're not making
a recursive call.
That is what I would
consider the base case.
That really comes from induction
and from the mathematics
of recursion.
You want to have a base
case and then the recursion
is really the inductive step.
If that doesn't make too much
sense, don't worry about it.
You can think of
it syntactically.
Look for a path in
the code where you
don't see RGCD inside of RGCD.
And you can clearly see
that in the if m mod n
equals equals 0, return n.
So you want to have
what we call the base
case where a function returns.
That's not enough
because you don't quite
know if you're going to get
to that base case or not.
You're going to call this
function with some arguments,
and you want to get some
sense that the arguments are
shrinking as you go.
And it could even be
the other way around.
The arguments may
increase, and once you
grow beyond a certain threshold,
you fire off on the return
without making the
recursive call.
So this notion of the
arguments becoming smaller
is very common in the case
of the algorithmic paradigm
that we'll be
following in this class
where we're going to take
large problems like a eight
queens or n queens and
go to n minus 1 queens
and n minus 2 queens.
And divide and conquer, which is
other paradigm that we look at.
As you can see from the
name is taking a big problem
and making it smaller.
So really for the
most part, you're
going to essentially have
a situation where you're
going to say that the
arguments to the function
should be smaller in some sense.
And smaller could mean bigger.
I mean, it's just a
definitional thing.
I mean, the point is when
you get to the base case,
usually you are saying, as
you can see in this base case,
you're saying when it
comes down to the fact
that a particular condition
is satisfied, in this case,
it's the relationship
between m and n.
And if that's 0,
then we return n.
But in other cases,
it just might
be when you get to a one
queen problem, you're done.
I mean, you have no choice.
You've got this 1 by
1 board and you've
got to put your queen on
it, and obviously, that
might create a conflict,
but you're done.
I mean, there's no
two things about it
if you have one queen problem.
There's only one step.
You put your queen down.
So that's where we were at
with respect to the puzzles
that we're going to
be doing in this class
where you're going to
shrink things down.
So in that sense, smaller
would mean smaller.
It's not necessarily in quotes.
So that makes sense?
Any questions at all
about syntax or anything
that you see on the board here?
All right good.
So now, I'm ready to show
you what the n queens
code looks like.
One of the other
problems, of course,
with the eight queens
code is that it only
works for eight queens, and
it doesn't work for nine.
And that's annoying,
so you'd like
to have a procedure that takes
n as an argument and works
for n equals 4, n equals 8.
And eventually, you could
run this on n equals 20,
and it will finish.
I'll show you.
But there is an
exponential relationship
between run time and
n because it's just
a complicated problem.
There's a lot of combinations.
So you do not want to run this
code for more than n equals 25.
It hasn't completed.
I think at some point I
did an analysis on how long
it would take for n
equals 30, and it wasn't
something I wanted to wait for.
I mean, my computer
would have gotten old
and died before the
program came back.
Which is a reasonable
experiment to carry out,
but I like my computer.
I'm kind of annoyed with it
because of the new operating
system, but I generally like it.
So you can see that
we're going to use
exactly the same framework.
We're going to use the
same no conflicts routine.
There's no change there, no
change in data structures.
There's no change in really
even the incremental strategy
that we're following.
But we can take
that intuitive code
and turn it into this pretty
code that has about five lines,
or seven lines, what have you.
And so you can see, again,
that if you look at that code,
I mean, it's not that
much more complicated.
There's more going on in there.
There's more going on because
it's a more interesting problem
at some level than GCD, but it
has the same characteristics
in terms of having a base case,
and it's actually an easy one
to look at.
And it also has
a property 2 here
where the argument
to the nQueens
is going to be one less than
what the caller function has
as its argument because
you're going column by column,
and you're taking away.
In this case, you're not
necessarily going to a 7
by 7, really.
It's not that you're going
from 8 by 8 to 7 by 7.
You're going from
8 by 8 to 7 by 8.
You have one less column.
You still have to work
with all the rows.
So that's really what's
going on out here.
If current equal size--
so what's happening is current
is actually incrementing.
So you're moving and what is
remaining is becoming smaller.
And current starts with--
so if you look at
nQueens here, it
says nQueens, a
size, and rQueens,
which is this routine here,
it sets current to be 0.
And size is, of course,
whatever you give nQueens,
which could be 8 or 20.
And finally, if you look
at this part of the code,
you get to the point
where you run out
of columns when
current equals size.
And at this point, you
put all the queens down,
and that things
haven't fallen apart--
you haven't returned false--
and therefore, you're done.
So when you get to that
quote ninth column,
you're off the board,
and you're done.
And all of the existing
queens, the eight queens
that were put on
the board, didn't
conflict with each other.
That's how it works.
And then over here, you've
taken your eight loops that
were in the eight queens problem
or the for loops in the four
queens problem and
you've gone off
and turned it into one loop.
And the reason that
works is because rQueens
is calling rQueens out here.
So that's your recursive call.
And then the argument
here is current plus 1,
and it's getting closer
and closer to size
as you go around, which
means that it's effectively
getting smaller.
What you're working
with is getting smaller.
So if of look at
what happens here,
you can trace the
execution of this,
and this is worthwhile doing.
And I'll put this in the notes,
and you can look at it for a 4
by 4.
But in general, if you're
confused about recursion,
it's absolutely
worthwhile to trace
the execution for
small arguments
and figure out exactly
when things are terminating
and when things are
being called recursively.
And this is simply
a single call.
It looks like it's a single
call, because there's
only one instance of rQueens.
But if you look at the
code, how many calls would
I possibly make if I were
sitting with an eight queens
problem and I started
with size equals 8?
Then in that very
first, I invoke rQueens
with current equal
0 and size equals 8.
How many rQueens calls will
the first rQueens make?
How many times would
potentially make that?
So if I look at the branching
here and I say this is rQueens
and this has current
equals 0 and size equals 8,
the way you want to think about
this from a tracing standpoint
is you're making calls.
rQueens is calling rQueens.
And obviously, there is
rQueens in the middle
of that code over there.
And so what is the
breadth here in terms
of the number of calls?
Someone?
Trace the code.
So i in range 8, which
means 0 through 7,
and then I'm going to go off,
and this is the very first one.
So noConflicts is going
to constantly return--
it's the first queen.
So noConflicts is going
to constantly return true.
So I'm going to go
inside of the if,
and I'm going to make
that rQueens call.
So I'm going to have eight
different calls associated
with each of the
positions that corresponds
to the queen on
that first column.
And then each of these
could potentially
make eight different
calls, potentially I
said because as you get
deeper in the recursion,
the noConflicts is
going to fire false,
and it may not make the call.
But obviously, the
very first one, you're
going to make eight calls.
So recursion is scary from
a performance standpoint
to some people and rightly so
because things could explode
on you, and this
goes back to what
I said about running
this with n r size
equals 25 and so
on and so forth.
And one of the things
that is worth doing
and you have to do this type of
analysis in classes like 6.006,
not a lot of this
but because we don't
do exponential algorithms.
But you can look
at this tree that
is being generated by
these recursive calls
and you do want to get some
sense of how large this tree is
going to become.
And we're going to look at a
different class of algorithms.
Most of algorithms
we're going to look
at that are recursive for the
rest of this course including
the next one that we'll
get to in a few minutes,
aren't as bad as
this one in terms
of computational complexity.
But n queens is a hard problem.
It needs exhaustive search, and
there's a lot of combinations.
And so it's not an
efficient algorithm.
Efficient means
polynomial times something
like n square quadratic,
n cubed, and so on.
And this is not efficient,
and the reason for that
is this explosion in the
number of recursive calls.
So it's easy to write five
lines of code that takes forever
to run.
It will terminate.
It's not that it had
an infinite loop in it,
but the number of combinations
explodes on you because
of eight and then eight again
for each of these and then--
and so on.
So you can see that gets
pretty large pretty quick.
So this code is something
that, as I said,
is essentially the same.
It's sitting there
computing nQueens 20.
That's why this is not a problem
with my laptop, at least,
as of this moment, I don't think
it's a problem with my laptop.
And so there you go.
So nQueens 20 gave you the
representation that we chose.
You can try and
convince yourself
that this, in fact, is correct.
I haven't.
But that code is so
straightforward at this point
that if there is
anything wrong with it,
it would be
catastrophically wrong.
It would just crash or it
wouldn't return anything.
And so that is one solution.
There's many, many solutions.
Unlike the eight queens case,
where I ran it to completion
and all the 92 solutions
got printed out,
there's millions
of solutions here.
So if I just took out a return
statement and let it run,
you'll get screen
fulls of solutions
to the 20 queens problem
because if you did that, there
would be a lot of solutions.
But especially given
that we are not
exploiting rotational
symmetry and reflections,
there's a lot of solutions.
But that's one of them.
So there you go.
Yeah.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Is there an expression
for the number of solutions
you'll get, that depends on n?
SRINI DEVADAS: No.
There's no closed form solution.
No.
The 12 is a concrete number,
and 92 and 12 were enumerated.
Now you could obviously write a
computer program that counted--
I mean, you didn't
have to print this out.
You could count the
number of solutions
to the 20 queens problem,
and you can find that out.
But then if you want to do
rotations and reflections,
you'd have to start
shaving things off.
Yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: Do you have the run
time for the recursive one?
Would that be n to the n?
SRINI DEVADAS: No.
Because you're doing
significant pruning.
Great question.
So some of these things get
truncated because you end up
doing this, and
then this one you
don't have to go any further.
So it's not n to the n
simply because you never
have to put down another
queen if the first two queens
conflict with each other.
So you likely did,
actually, been back
on Thursday about
this time yesterday,
we were going over the 4 by 4.
And we didn't even
put a queen down.
We went over and we
said, oh, this clearly
can't work because there's
a queen on this row already.
This clearly can't work because
there's a queen one a way.
So there's no
reason to go deeper.
You would go n raised to n if
you only did the conflict check
after you put n queens down.
And if you put
all n queens down,
closed your eyes put n queens
down and then ran a conflict
check, and then did
that over and over,
over and over, it
would be n raised to n.
But that's not what we're doing.
What we're doing is if you look
at the code, we are saying if--
this is an important
statement, actually.
Thanks for the question.
That is pruning your
search, and that
is making it significantly
less than n raised to n.
A nice exercise.
Remember what I said about
opportunity for homework,
when I get questions.
A nice exercise is to
go to 8 raised to 8
and then go to the
eight queens problem
and figure out
what that number is
in terms of the number
of times you're actually
checking for no conflicts.
So count the number of times,
not the number of solutions,
but the number of times
noConflicts is being called,
and you'll find that it's
significantly less than 8
raised to 8.
Because you're
pruning the search.
Technically, it's called pruning
the search high up in the tree.
That's the technical
term for it.
All right?
Good.
Any other questions?
So we're done with eight
queens and nQueens.